okay we have to draw a diagram for this
now um to draw a diagram for this you've
really got to understand what this whole
arg
notation business is about okay so i'm
going to build this step by step right
let's just think about alexander what is
arguable right well it means you you
have some complex number z
right and augze means well okay what's
the angle
measured from the origin
right uh it's capital a so it's the
principal argument okay so that's what
arg said is about therefore what are
args n minus one and arg z plus one
about they're still about measuring an
angle aren't they but how is it
different
so so the whole idea is yeah there's a
shift right um the way i like to think
about it is it's measuring an angle
again it's still arg right but it's
measuring it from a different place okay
so for um z plus one oops one color
z plus one i'm gonna measure from here
yeah right so i'm gonna get
this kind of angle here
in here
is that okay
that angle there this is my new starting
point and there's my principal argument
so that argument there is r of z plus
one
okay
and then for r z minus one is it like
that like you don't
yeah yeah because it's
yeah that's right it's a young zeb oh
dear um and i'm shifted okay really
quickly let's just see if the class is
coming in here
um what day is it
okay so
r z minus one is shifted the other way
yeah right so there's my hand
okay now you do need to remember that
when you're doing this right um this is
um this is equivalent to r z minus one
minus r of z plus one
okay now then your question becomes
what's the quickest way in this diagram
to relate these two blue arguments
right
and the answer is it looks to me like
exterior angle of a triangle okay in
this situation here
this angle is equal to some of the two
opposite interior angles right so i'm
going to call this theta
right so r of
z minus one equals arg of the two this
is the two opposite interior angles
right and now you can see this
you see all i need to do is bring this
over
okay so i'm going to do that in a shifty
way that minus that equals theta
okay but it's equal to pi and four so
now i know what this angle in the corner
is yeah pi and four now this is just one
example of a z that satisfies this
um this particular pump this value that
i'm given right so i can draw a whole
bunch of other ones it traces out a
locus what locus does it trace
yeah so it falls apart a circle because
angles standing on the same chord right
this arc here
they're going to all stand they're all
going to be in the same segment okay so
here's what we get
also you can move you can move that
point yeah that's right so just like if
i gave you a circle right and you're
like it's a very perfect circle thank
you
okay so here's a and b right and it's
like let me just suppose that uh this
angle here is gonna be pine four right
it's like well that means every other
angle that's drawn off the same answer
or be pi on four they'll all be in the
same
segment so z could be anywhere along the
line that's right any any of these can
be said and any of these
could be said